there's been no response to the
sanctions from russia's President
Vladimir Putin is focused on this
weekend's election where he's seeking
another term against little opposition
other officials are denouncing the u.s.
move and Britain's claim that Russia
eight Russian agents attacked a former
spy in England Elizabeth Palmer is
outside the Kremlin in Moscow Elizabeth
good morning good morning the new US
sanctions haven't grabbed the headlines
here because the big story is still the
presidential election now only 48 hours
away but one Russian official has
responded to Washington he is Sergei
Ryabkov the Deputy Foreign Minister he
said Russia would expand what it calls a
blacklist of Americans who can't visit
or do business in Russia as for the
street power poisoning case this morning
russia's Foreign Minister Sergey Lavrov
said Russia will soon expel British
diplomats in a tit-for-tat retaliation
for the 23 Russians who've already been
told to leave Britain Lavrov also
accused Britain of refusing to share a
sample of the nerve agent used to attack
the script house but Britain is giving a
sample to the organization for the
prohibition of chemical weapons and the
Russians should have access to it the UK
says the chemical is Nova chock a weapon
concocted secretly in Soviet times but
Russia has never publicly admitted to
having Nova chok and in fact last night
the Deputy Foreign Minister flat-out
denied that it had ever been developed
here which does not bode very well for
any investigation that's trying to get
to the truth Norah alright and Elizabeth
Palmer in Moscow thank you